اه كيف
تصف الجمهوريه الاسلاميه حاليا كيف تعرفها
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه بعد ثوره عام 79 فان
الهيكليه السياسيه كانت قائمه على ركيزتين
الاولى
هي
الطائفه الشيعيه والثانيه الحرس الثوري
الاولى هي الانقسام
الشعب الحكام
التوالي مسؤولياتي ايران والحرس الثوري
كان يحميه من الاعتياجات الداخليه
والخارجيه وهنالك اختلاف كبير جدا بين
ايران والعديد من الانظمه الاخرى في الدول
الاخرى
مثلا الطبقه السياسيه في الشرق الاوسط
كانت تستغل القوات الشرطه لحمايه نفسها من
الاعداء المحليين والجيش لحمايه النزاهه
اراضي الدوله
في كل مره يتدخل فيها الحارسه
النظام ضد الخصومه السياسيه المحليين
فالحارسه اوريكانيه يجب ان يتلقى شيئا
بالمقابل او مقابل السياسيه
وكذلك ان نفود على اتخاذ القرارات
الاستراتيجيه وهذا التطور وبشكل تدريجي
جعل من ايران اولها من في اخرى عطيه
النظام يقودها هؤلاء علم الشيعه الى
دكاتوريه عسكريه والحرسه الدوري لا يحمي
فقط النظام ضد الاعداء داخلي والخارجين
بشكل متزايده في اداره شؤون الدوله